[Music]
I'd like to welcome everybody to
tonight's just tactics class we're going
to go over to two topics the first topic
is perpetual check and that's pretty
straightforward so there's only three
examples and then we move into a Rick on
the open file and getting the seventh
rank and how you can attack with with a
work on the seventh rank and we have a
large number of examples about ten there
so the first example I'd like to go
through is perpetual check now perpetual
check is what you do what it's a
defensive technique when you're losing
the game and you're desperately looking
around for a counter-attack and a way to
get a draw so look at this position and
you'll see that white has two rooks and
two knights and black only has a bishop
so white is a knight and two rooks up so
I'd say black is desperate
so black to play to find a perpetual
check what would be the waited to get
that Bishop takes G to check now if King
takes bishop which is the mainline of
course
then what's the follow-up move Queen to
g4 and the King has to go back in the
corner and then Queen f3 check and you
just repeat back and forth g4 and f3
this first example is very simple just
to get the I the main idea across all
these examples are taken from the game
of chess by Steinberg tarish published
in 1935 he was a German off
now what happens if white moves the King
to g1 that's a bad move but how does a
black take advantage of it what would be
blacks move here Matt Bishop takes f1
black remember black is 2 works in a
knight down so winning a rook for
bishops not going to cut it black has to
play for checkmate or perpetual check
you he's going to try to play for
checkmate here Queen to g4 perhaps let's
look at it now the threat is Bishop to
f3 which is checkmate
the only possible move is pawn up and
what's what blacks follow up
Bishop takes pawn check King up Queen
down - geez - check that's the obvious
move King up here looks like the Kings
going to escape over to the Queen side
so let's back up Queen the g4s an
interesting idea but it doesn't quite
cut it
what's another idea why didn't Queen the
g4 work white could attack the Queen
with the pawn can we make a move and
block the pawn what move would that be
Bishop to f3 and then we threaten Queen
the g4 check and mate and now there's no
way White can stop the checkmate because
there's no checks by the White Queen and
the White Knight can't check anything
and the uruk's can't go anywhere
and if h3 well we can do Queen takes
pawn or we could do Queen to g5 check
King to rook to that and Queen the g2
would be checkmate alright so that's
pretty straightforward let's go on to
the next example this one will be a
little more complicated
okay so right off the bat we see that
the black Bishop on d5 is attacking the
White Queen well we see that the bishop
is protected by the Queen the black
Queen and the Black Knight the Black
Knights pinned by the White Queen the
rook could take the knight with check
pulling the Queen away from the bishop
so we could win two pieces for the rook
by rook takes Knight Queen takes Queen
takes bishop is there any other move
besides rook takes Knight check for
white I don't see a better move so let's
look at it let's see what happens or it
takes a knight check Queen takes now
what does black play
remember tonight's topic is perpetual
check as a defense do you see the
perpetual check back here work in the
Queen check the the black coin check the
white King
how about you yes Queen the e1 and
notice that the queen is also hitting
the h4 pawn the king has to go to work
too so that that pretty much gives it
away then Queen takes pawn check and you
just move the Queen back and forth and
you get your perpetual check and a draw
and you need that because White has the
advantage with the two minor pieces
against Rick plus the black works not in
play
White's about to checkmate black
otherwise so you have to take the
perpetual check okay we have one more
example on perpetual check it's black to
play White's Knight is unprotected so
black takes the knight what does white
play white place for perpetual check and
gets one
there's only one check by the White
Queen Queen f5 check that either works
or it doesn't work if pawn comes up
Queen takes pawn check and we just go
between f7 and f8 perpetual and if the
King goes back well then we just go to
c8 remember the black Queen prevented
Queen the c8 but when the black Queen
took our Knight it freed up the c8
square for the White Queen so we get the
perpetual check by coming down here and
we just repeat so that's the draw now
the next topic is a little more
complicated it's ten examples of a rook
on an open file with the idea of
penetrating to the seventh rank and you
can attack across your opponent's
seventh rank all the pawns that are
lined up pieces and you have a King side
attack e if they're no pawns stopping
the rook from getting to the king
naturally the rook has to be supported
by a queen of bishop or Knight at least
one other piece so that's what we'll be
looking for in these examples well
there's no work on anywhere near or
seventh rank in this position but I
think we can see that it's probably
white because White's positions better
notice how the black bishops the black
Bishop on b7 is blocked by the white
pawns on d5 a6 and b5 and b6 notice how
the black knight is behind his pawns on
d7 can't the only square he can go to is
the b6 but he can't get to c4 and going
to a4 doesn't make much sense so there's
not any good moves for that night and
the black squared bishop on e7 is
hindered by the white pawns which are on
the black squares e5 f 4 and b4
also note that the black king is on the
second rank on f7 if we can get a rook
down mr. c7 then we can attack that
Bishop that's on b7 we can attack the
knight and pass the knight the bishop
and then toward the King so that kind of
begs the move rook to c1 which is our
first move
now black cast to try to defend and keep
White's going to double rooks on the C
file or by maybe like rook to c3 and Rik
f1 to c1 and then he can even bring his
queen over to c2 and have all three
major pieces on the C file so black can
test the file by moving his a rook over
to c8 to trade rooks now while white
needs to continue his attack now he
could do rook takes rook because blacks
rook can't take back because that's
blocked by the Queen and if Queen takes
rook then we could do Rick to c1 the
rook on c1 is protected by the bishop at
e3 and the knight on B three the Queen
would move and but then say the Queen
would go to b8 and then he would black
would bring the other work to c8 and try
to trade that last Rick off so it's not
sure how that works out but let's see
what white does okay
why didn't trade rooks first he attacks
the bishop by moving Knight to a5 that
bishop is unprotected so blacks problem
is he has to defend or move the bishop
on B 7 + the essence defend the C file
so he's he's got to make a file and
Bishop on b7 Betty
to be concerned about let's see
he just retreats the bishop notice
though that the white knights the d4
Knight in the a5 night they can drop in
on c6 and they would have an attack on
the Queen and the bishop on e7 so white
can penetrate on the C file we're not
yet ready to get a rook to the seventh
rank but the Knights can lead the way
into blacks position okay so first we
did Rick takes rook Queen takes now that
rook comes over now the Queen either has
to go to b8 or to d8 he goes to be eight
because he wants to leave c8 free to
bring the rook over to trade rook so if
the Queen had gone to d8 then he
couldn't bring the rook over so BH
really the best move now I think we
dropped one of the nights in the c6
let's see oh no we don't drop the knight
in
not yet we bring the Queen over so that
so the queen is on e2 Black is
threatening work to c8 by bringing the
Queen to c2 we prevent that black can't
oppose the rook so you see by play
Knight to a5 we drove the bishop back
from b7 to a8
if we hadn't played that move the bishop
would be on b7 protecting the c8 squared
and the work could come over and our
Queen move wouldn't have had any effect
so that's why this started out with
Knight to a5 first alright so up but
locked in serious trouble here
white controls the C file and is
threatening Queen to c7 and at which
were threatened Queen takes Knight Queen
takes Queen rook takes the rook would
threaten the
and black can't oppose the work on the C
file the other threat White has is he
can drop one of his knights in to c6
forking the Queen and the black squared
bishop and if he moves the d4 Knight it
opens up that diagonal for the bishop on
e3 can come up and attack on the black
diagonal from c5 after Knight takes
Bishop on the e7 King takes we could
possibly play Bishop to c5 check anyway
we'll see what happens
okay so black retreats the bishop he
wants to take that night to simplify the
position the knight drops into c6 again
forking the Queen the Queen moves up to
b7 the knight takes the bishop rook
takes the knight now notice that the
black square bishop is gone so there's
no protection for those black squares
notice that the white bishop on e3 is on
a black square and that bishop can fall
back to f2 go up to h4 and come in that
diagonal where the bishop can stay where
she's at and operate toward the c5 the
black rook can't oppose the black Bishop
is blocked by the Queen on b7 so and
again black's knight blacks in a lot of
trouble let's see what happens okay
white immediately grabs the seventh rank
and threatens Queen takes Queen Bishop
takes and then the RIC comes down
threatens to the bishop and the knight
if the bishop moves back the rook can go
to a 7 and win that a e6 pawn let's see
what black does black just retreats cuz
he would rather he doesn't want to have
a bishop it he doesn't run a lot Queen
takes Queen Bishop rook to the 7th
attacking the bishop he'd rather have
Queen takes Queen rook to
eggs then work to the seventh he can
protect the night with the King back to
e8 and he doesn't lose the move by
having to move his bishop okay
now white retreats the bishop to f2 he's
contemplating going to h4 attacking the
work on d8 Queen moves up to b6
the Queen is attacking the knight
obviously the bishop can't do the
intended move Bishop to h4 because it
would leave the knight unprotected Queen
takes Knight check but the Queen just
moved in there's a battery it looks like
oh it I was thinking Knight takes F pawn
the bishop would be attacking the Queen
but Queen takes Queen would be a
sufficient answer rook takes Queen then
we can do pawn takes Knight but the fact
that the queen is on the same day I know
what the bishop looks bad let's see what
white does white retreats the knight
back to f3 attacking the Queen and the
knight heads toward g5 where it would be
Czech attacking the King in that weak
pawn on e6 looks like black has to do
Queen takes Queen Bishop takes Queen
attacking the knight the King goes back
to protect the knight that frees the
rook up and it gets the King out of the
way of the knight check now the bishop
comes to h4 attacking the rook the rook
can't go to c8 so the wreck has to go to
b8 now the night goes to g5 and attacks
the week e6 pawn the knight drops back
to protect the weak east six pawn
okay now the night the white night goes
from g5 to f7 and the threat is Knight
to e6 check check me yeah cuz the bishop
guards the black square okay so the
knight has to go up there to give the
King an escape square the knight checks
the King has to is forced away from the
knight and rook takes Knight and that is
how the rook penetrated to the seventh
remember we swapped off the black the
bishop that was on black squares for
black that allowed our work to go to c7
and our Bishop that's on h4 was able to
move from e3 to f2 and the h4 cuz there
was no opposing bishop so the bishop and
the rook could coordinate along the
seventh rank and penetrate into blacks
position winning the game well obviously
white is the only one penetrating any
open files with the rook White has a
rook on h4 protected by a bishop on g3
the problem is what looks like if it's
White's move why could just move down to
h7 and with threatened rook takes pawn
on c7 so let's see what happens
yep rook down
now what happens if black defends the
pawn with rook to c8 what happens then
oh we could do that but look out not
only are we threatening the pawn on c7
we're threatening rook to f7 check
forcing the King to a white square and
then we can put our queen on a four on
the white diagonal the King moves over
to d8 we have Queen to d7 checkmate
that's stronger than attacking the Queen
so let's see black had to block that
diagonal so he moved the pawn there so
to block Queen to a4 check so
unfortunately for black white can just
go to b4 and threaten Queen takes pawn
now once that's not just Queen takes
pawn and remember first instruct f7
check King to e8 then it's going takes
pawn check so black doesn't have time to
do Queen the e3 attacking the bishop
because we've got checkmate threatened
so let's see what black comes up with oh
he moved his knight let's see if there's
any other move what would white do if
black protected the pawn with a six this
isn't in the in the author's book but
what would black white do here look that
look we have a bishop on g3 attacking
what pawn d6 and our Queens on that pawn
and that's with check the King would
have to move over and then we'd have
Queen to d7 checkmate
or King back to f/8 then queen or rook
to f7 checkmate so that's the answer
Bishop takes pawn check let's see what
black did black moves the knight I don't
see that that helps him oh if rook to f7
he can go the other direction but then
he loses his Knight so let's see what
white does oh he moves there anyway
Queen takes pawn check now if he moves
over so he has to do pawn up now all we
do is Queen to the seventh threat and
Queen takes Knight
not to mention Queen to d7 checkmate
there's no way to defend both those
threats so that's that let's look at the
position a little bit
I believe black wins to this position I
think it's blacks move and our theme is
worked to the seventh so the obvious
move is rook to f2 attacking toward the
King on that's on h2 notice that our
bishop on diest the black Bishop on d7
is undefended and attacked by the knight
but white can't afford to do Knight
takes bishop because that night on c5 is
guarding the b3 square so if the knight
takes to the bishop then there's the
rather nice checkmate Queen to b3
checkmate
so black doesn't have to be worried
about that
leaving that Bishop hanging on d7 so
again I think we're looking at Rick to
f2 let's see yep worked f2 okay now the
knight comes back that attacks the rook
and it allows the Queen to protect the
b3 square to prevent Queen to b3 and it
also threatens Knight takes bishop on
the black queen
so it looks like a pretty decent move
white is threatening to pieces at one
time of course so we know blacks going
to win so all we have to do is find the
win for black okay
I think the who sees the win for black
what's blacks winning move here so I
think Knight to c4 is the move maybe I
said c5 Knight to c4 yeah so the work
has to come over and protect that's
interesting though it takes away a
retreat square for the King you see that
the King can't go to g1 now so I wonder
if there's some way we can find to
attack the King again white seems to be
threatening two of our pieces at one
time I think I see a good move for black
does anyone have any suggestions for
black remember White's threatening
Knight takes bishop but what does when
the knight takes the bishop on d7 that
night was protecting some white squares
back in White's position we already set
mention g3 right there's another key
white square that that Knight protects
what square is that when the Knights on
c5 I mean it protects a couple key white
squares in White's position what's the
other one besides b3 a for okay what
else is protecting a for methane maybe
we move up our queen and attack a four
that prevents
am i threatening queen a3 what's to
prevent him from doing Knight takes rook
yeah I don't see that okay so maybe
Queen to b4 comes later looks like we're
going to have to move our rook we need
to move our rook somewhere strong
because Knight takes bishop is going to
threaten our queen right where's this we
move the rook what's the strongest
threat we can make with the black rook
yeah attack the Queen rook to d2 is my
guess
okay now if Knight takes bishop
we don't do rook takes Queen because
Knight takes Queen he would be on our
rook right but we have that move we
talked about Dennis Queen to g4
threatening Queen takes pawn check right
and we're on the Queen but could the
Queen go to g3 in that case I mean b3
maybe the Queen could just go to b3 to
protect the pawn and do we have anything
so we take the Queen let's go back and
just take the Queen Knight Tate okay
okay white does Knight takes bishop
right we take the Queen he takes our
queen we could take
his queen with our he we could take his
night with our night then we would have
a night we would have two rooks and we'd
have a bishop on g5 right and he would
only have one night left right so he'd
be a piece up let's see what the author
says okay no he he moved the Queen okay
so I guess we that would win we would do
rook takes Queen we would win a piece so
he moved the Queen attacks our Bishop
now we move our queen up so if Knight
takes of course Queen takes pawn is
checkmate
oh this is kind of pretty Queen takes
bishop who sees the checkmate now yeah
let's just do it that's it so Dennis you
had the idea we just didn't we had to
work out the order to get it quite right
well this is pretty obvious that black
is the attacker obviously black can do
Brooke to f7 and graph F to grab the
seventh ranked threatened rook to c2
King over or takes pawn check and
checkmate to follow the question is is
there a defense for white so if we play
rook to f2 for black white has to guard
the c2 square
now it looks like white it would have a
couple choices white could play work to
d2 where the works protected by the
queen and the king or he could try Queen
to c3 if he does Rick to d2 though
notice that the book the other black
work is attacking the d4 pot so we could
trade the rook the rook and the Queen
the King would come to d2 and we'd ever
take spawn check and we might have a
winning ending we'd have four pawn we'd
have white would have four pawns and
black would have two four six pawns so
work the d2 is not going to cut it let's
see what white tries okay work here Oh
Queen takes pawn guarding c2 okay now we
shouldn't let we're attacking black is
attacking black would be foolish to
allow the trade of Queens I believe but
if black plays Queen takes pawn looks
like white could play worked two h1
attacking the Queen and the Queen moves
we would have Queen takes rook pawn
check right but the Queen can move was
checked there's an F for square or
that's check that would force the trade
of Queens Queen takes Queen rook takes
Queen then we would have two rooks on
the d4 pawn the d4 pawn can't be
defended and it can't advance so it
looks like we would win the ending so I
think Queen takes rook pawn
okay so he took the c-pawn we already
said rook to h1 doesn't work now it
looks like we have rook takes B pawn
that looks pretty good
anybody see anything better let's see
yep where it takes B pawn I bet I bet
it's Queen takes c7 nope
Queen to c3
now what does black do
oh yeah that's the right move rook to B
D to b8
okay threatening checkmate it doesn't
look like there's any good defense
he tries Queen over so he'll give up the
Queen for the two rooks ah but we have a
nice check
he can't interpose the Queen if he
interposes the rook if he interposes the
rook we can do work down check King the
see to the other work King up there to
c3 and we can do work to b3 check and
when the Queen so he has to go here now
we jump over to c3 and that's it
he has no move Queen to c3 Queen takes
Queen checkmate alright obviously White
has the two rooks doubled on the e-file
so we're gonna talk about the rooks
penetrating to e7 can't do the rook to
e7 though our Queens attacked by that
night notice that the knight on d5 is
unprotected and noticed that with the
pawn structure on the black King side
that the black squares are weak the f6
square and the h6 square the white
knight in white queen are on those
squares and dominate those squares so
that should suggest the witty move who
would like to propose the winning move
for white here
we're not going to check me we're going
for a winning ending we're going to go
to the seventh ranked with the rook and
attack the b-pawn and the app the the
beat pawn on b7 in the pawn on F maybe
we'll even be able to double rooks up or
something I'm not sure how it's all
going to shake out but we're playing for
the better nd not to check me any ideas
okay well I said the f6 is a whole right
now we could do night check the King
would have to go to h8 we'd have to move
our queen say to f4 to protect the night
well look that other pesky night no the
other night couldn't go to h5 because
we'd have Knight takes Knight and we are
threatening Queen takes Knight on g5
remember our Knights on f6 so it blocks
the Queen protecting the Black Knight
maybe but our Queens on f4 he could move
his knight on g7 over to e6 where it
attacks our Queen on f4 and protects the
knight on d5 at the same time and our
Queen can only go to one square that
protects the knight on f6 the Queen
could go to e5 and that would threaten a
discover check by the knight on f6 movie
so I would say it's not clear Knight to
f6 is not clear what's going to happen
better for white is to go in with the
Queen that takes the Queen there threat
basically the thread is Queen takes
Queen and then rook to e7 followed up by
Knight to f6 so moving the Queen in it
got the Queen out of danger from the
Black Knight and we capitalized on the
weak black squares in the blacks King
side position so but black felt nothing
better than that now the King moved over
now look at the rather pitiful position
of blacks pieces his King is stuck in
the corner his Knights are on g7 + g5
not doing a whole lot now that they can
move to e6 though and block that efile
well we're going to grab the e-file
before he can block it and then it will
threaten the pawn on b7 and at some
point we can drop our night from f6 to
d7 and it can attack the rook on f8 and
when the rook moves off f8 we might be
able to take our akane 7 and take the
pawn on f7 of course we have to drive
the night from g4 first with a move like
h4 the knight moves and then we take the
f7 pawn and probably win the game so
rook down he moves his rook over oh and
we fork them that's easy enough so
that's all there was to that let's call
up the notation
if he moved the other work over he would
have avoided the night fork of the two
rooks right and protected the pawn but
look how bad the rooks are they looked
silly there at b8 Nate behind Fonz you
never want to do that so so now we try
to win the pawn on f7 we drive the
knight back 19 and we take the pawn and
that's a one game oh and there's a note
I would probably just take the pawn and
be happy the note says even stronger is
h5 continuing the attack now if Knight
takes pawn Knight takes Knight pawn
takes Knight we do rook takes pawn and
that night that's left on e6 is hanging
and if the knight moves we can drop the
two routes and threatened rook takes
rook pawn check that's why h5 is
stronger he can try Knight to f4 we
attack the knight on GC he moves the
knight here we move the night here
attack and now Oh
his knight on f4 is on our Bishop so all
we have to do is retreat the bishop and
he has no good defense against rook
takes pawn followed by the other we're
coming down so that wins however work
takes f7 is perfectly fine try most of
us would do that so that's right there's
another possibility night 5 2 e 6 we
just take the pawn and we have a1 ending
Rick f2b 8 we take the f7 pawn and win
okay very good
well that are covered for tonight thanks
for coming
[Music]
you